non puoi capire mi annoio tro il pd
persone in quarantena
iscriviti al canale per non perdere
neanche un video le serie ma secondo te
piovesse tutto ho visto tutte le sere su
next surprise disney plus nesso memoria
o addirittura fatto il cambio armate di
mia spontanea volontà
ho comprato cose su amazon non
utilizzerò mai giusto per passare il
tempo
se fai parte di questa categoria
iscriviti al canale sicuramente qualche
video sarei perso la mostra scioccata ma
tu ti rendi conto ciacci gente che si
lamenta perché deve stare a casa ma c'è
neanche senso c'è manca perché no eve
jolie sono quelli che criticano chi
critica la gente chi critica quelli che
escono e lo rispettano le regole
c'è ma ognuno sarà libero di criticare
chi vuole criticare amici sono i momenti
come questi che dobbiamo tirare fuori
tutta la nostra positività perché la
vita un viaggio meraviglioso fatto di
alti e bassi e quando pensi che sia
finita è proprio allora che comincia la
salita
sono sicura che ce la faremo anche
stavolta un giorno tutto questo sarà
solo un lontano ricordo
torneremo ad abbracciarci state positive
my friends oggi cucino un super dolce la
ricetta di oggi è davvero molto semplice
basteranno pochissimi ingredienti
vediamoli insieme
allora 2 3 uova medio piccolo grande di
tre galloni di latte intero magro 0,661
libbre di farina 0.0 dice quadrata di
3,5 delle barre di cioccolato belga e
della cannella delle colline del perù ma
iniziamo subito nova bacia che mi
arrendo e mamma esagerate sempre che
pulisce esagerata un bar paypal ma non
sapete quanto i microbi e germi ci sono
lì fuori
il virus compete loro eventuale 15 10
questo è il caldo quante volte vi siete
lavati le mani e 10 non bastano dieci
cento mille mani che si lasciano da
valore di di inventare
le scarpe vestiti case libri
l'autobianchi fogli di giornale che se
non valgono niente per lo meno ma mi
sento la febbre ti giuro mi sento
novembre sento caldo 1 st bisogno sto
misurando adesso ti dico 36 tra le basse
troppo basse
forse non lo so ma mi sento strana
digiuno anche un po faticato il cookie
romantico la pellicola e ho provato
dello zucchero un cucchiaio di zucchero
che non sapeva di zucchero mamma cosa
vuol dire come dove l'ho preso bartolo
blue air sale e non mi devo fermare i
ragazzi io voglio vedervi 16 con i
generici di pucciani questi aprile 1 e 2
ace e 4 le chiappe io ne voglio vedere
arrivare fino in argentina ok ho ancora
io voglio vedere non vedo non vedo
sorriso sorriso servito ragazzi ancora
12 dovete essere felice e bellissimo
cruciali galleria euro
ancora più forti ancona dopo la goldin e
devo dire che il feedback dei clienti è
stato assume positivo e sicuramente
rappresentazioni di marina ha giocato
colon fondamento gravi che ci tengo a
ringraziare personalmente a nome
dell'azienda marina gr grazie a voi e la
pena da parte mia anche del direttore
che tra l'altro è qui con me avrebbe
tanto piacere di vederti e di salutarti
per ringraziarti appunto quasi come
fosse di persona e si attivi la
videocamera grazie così ti saluta si può
guardare
[Musica]
ma ti pare